살펴보겠습니다
어떤 동화책에 쪽수가 1쪽부터
240조까지
적혀 있을 때
숫자 3이 적혀 있는 쪽수는
얼마입니까 그건 얘들아
233과 같은 경우는 두 개가 아니라
몇 번 세야 돼 한 번 세야 된다는
걸 알 수 있어요 없어요 전 나는
이렇게 할래 세 자릿수가 있는데
10의 자리에 3일 때와
1의 자리에 3일대로 이렇게
나눠보겠습니다
이해됐어요 그럼 삼이 몇 번 들어
있어요
한 번만 들어 있어야 되겠지 그리고
무엇을 더 해야 돼
두 번 들어간 걸 더해주면 되겠어요
안 되겠어요 되겠죠 자 그런데 이때는
1쪽부터니까
0 0부터
이 9까지 쓸 수 있어요 없어요 있죠
어 그냥 이거를 3-3이 들어가는
경우를 한번 빼주는 것이 더 낫겠다
그치 그럼 이때는 몇 개야
30개가 되겠다 안 되겠어 되겠지 자
이때는요
0 0부터
2 3까지가 되겠어요 안 되겠어요
그러니까 이때는 몇 개가 되겠어
24개라고 할 수가 있겠죠
단 이때는요
033133 233이 있잖아 그럼 몇
개를 빼주면 되겠어요 세 개를 빼주면
되겠지 그럼 38호 21을 더하면 몇
개
51개라고 할 수 있겠습니다
어느 날 수요일하고 목요일 날짜를
더했더니 165래요
얘가 무엇을 배수야
5의 배수지 그럼 우리 이렇게 볼게
수요라고 목요일이
이렇게
우주가 있다고 한번 해봐서
그럼 얘는
실시 차이 나는 가혹부터 14가
차이가 나겠지
그러면은
얘는요 165 나누기 얼마가 되겠어
5가 되겠지 그럼 5 35 3 15
33인데 1차이잖아 그건 16과
17이 되겠어야 되겠어요 조심해야
될 거 수요일에 하루도 많을 수도
있잖아
그런데
얘는요
30 24 31로 끝났어요 안
끝났어요
끝났죠
2가 되겠지 그럼 무슨 요일이
되겠습니까
답은
화요일이 된다고 할 수 있겠네요
한번은 되게 쉬운 문제지
자 그럼 봐요
142857-142857이 반복된단
말이야
그럼 128을 내가
6으로 나눌게 그럼
20일이 되겠고 나머지가 2가 되는
거잖아 그럼 두 번째 수가 되니까
답은 뭐가 되겠어
자
4번으로 넘어가겠습니다 봐봐 생각했던
것보다 어려운 거 아니지 자 얘는
가우스 자세를 활용한
방법이라고 생각할 수가 있지만
이건 연립방정식이에요
첫 번째 수부터 일곱 번째 수까지
더하면 105렙 그럼 또
똥 똥 네모
이렇게 있을 때요 가운데 수는요 배고
배고 나누기 7이라고 할 수 있어요
없어요 그럼 얘는 얼마가 되겠어
15가 되겠어요 안 되겠어요 그럼
보자
처음으로 우리가 동그라미라고 하고요
늘어나는 이것을 공통된 차이라고 하는
거잖아 왜 1차이라고 안 했으니까
그건 공차를 세 보라고 하면 우리는
공통된 차이를
15라고 할 수 있어요 없어요
자 들었네 여기에서 12번째 수까지
더했어
그러면 봐요
이렇게 할 거야 싫어 하나
둘
셋
넷
다섯
여섯
하나 둘 셋 넷 다섯 여섯 일곱
여덟 아홉 열 열하나 열 줄이지
근데 여기에서 가운데 수는 어디 있어
여기가 되겠어요 안 되겠어
그러면은 우리가
얘는 여섯 묶음이니까 얘랑 얘를
더하면 얼마가 되겠어
50이 되는 거 알 수 있어요 없어요
그러면 여기는 봐
cv에서 세부 두개 더한 거랑
맞지
15에서 세모
세 개를 더한 것은
얼마라고 할 수 있어요
50이라고 할 수 있지 그럼 세모
다섯 개가요
20이 되겠다 안 되겠어 그럼 3분은
4가 되는 거잖아 그럼 동그라미를
얼마 되겠어 3이 되겠지 더 문제는
첫 번째 수는 3이 되는 것이
되겠고요 그 다음에 3 더하기
4 곱하기 11이 12번째 수가
되겠냐 안 되겠냐 그래서
답은 3과 47이 되겠습니다
어려워
요
얘들아 일주일이면 몇 시간 지난 거야
168시간이지 근데 나는 이렇게 할
거야 얼마씩 차이가 나
2분의
7분씩 차이가 난다고 할 수 있어요
없어요 하나는 3분이 빨리 가고
하나는 30초가 늦게 가니까 그거
곱하기 168을 해주면 되겠어 안
되겠어
84 곱하기 7이 되는 거잖아
87에
56이니까
588분이라고 할 수 있어요 없어요
이라고 할 수 있겠습니다
자 다음과 같이 앞면과 뒷면이 같은
수가 쓰이는 종이가 있대 자 이거는
우리가 지금까지 했던
종이접기 좀 활용이지 중요한 건 아래
있는 것이 위에 올라오는 건 알아요
자 그럼 가장 위에 보이는 거 하라고
했는데 중요한 건 가장 아래는요 첫
번째에서는이 가운데가 되겠어요 안
되겠죠
그 다음 안에는 얘가 되겠어요 안
되겠어 그다음 미를 구하라고 하는데
오른쪽보다는 왼쪽을 먼저 덮고 그
다음에 얘를 덮는 거잖아 그래서 답은
얼마가 되겠어 15가 되겠습니다
안쪽 것이 위로 올라오잖아
잘 봐요
얘를 이렇게 접었고 얘를 제일 위에
접었지 제일 위에 있는 것은 안쪽으로
들어가고 있잖아요 속으로 숨잖아
실만 봅시다
얘들아 7번을 공식이지
자 기억을 보면요
왼쪽으로 몇 칸 갈 수 있어 4칸
오른쪽으로 두 칸 위로 두 칸 아래는
세 칸이 되는 것을
6 8 48개지 자 이유는요
오른쪽으로
5칸
왼쪽으로 한 칸 위로네 칸 아래로
이제 안 알려져도 되겠지 이렇게
자 8번으로 넘어갈게 자 1번 서부터
300번까지
번호를 붙인
300명의 어린이가 있어요
자 그럼 보자
얘들아 이거는요 이렇게 생각하면 돼
1번하고 2번하고 3번하고 4번이
있어
얼마 차이야 전체
인원이라는 거 알 수 있어요 없어요
있죠 그럼 전체는 300명이니까
188이잖아
그런 역에서 내부를 뺀 것이
150명이 돼야 되지 그럼 결국 몇
번
38분하고 마주 본다는 걸 알 수
있겠습니다 어려운 거 아니었죠 자 두
번으로 넘어갈게요
자 1부터 1000까지 근데 이거는
내 자리까지 생각하지 말고
99까지만 생각해도 되겠어 안 되겠어
근데 갑자기 숫자의 9인수야
근데 어떤 친구들은 이거를 100번대
200번대해서 나누는 사람들도
있습니다
맞죠
근데 보자 한자리 쓸 때는 한계지
두 자릿수일 때는
18부터 조용 구현까지 몇 개
9개지 자 세 자릿수일 때는 좀
다르게 해 볼게요
이번에는 100번대
200번째
300번대
400번대
500번대
600번대
700번대
800번대
900번대가 있다고 해봐
100번대는 팔을 만드는 거니까
8개가 되겠어요
이때는 7개
6개 5개
4개가 되겠어요 안 되겠어요
맞나 아 잠깐만 아 다섯 개구나
아까
팔을 만들어야 되니까
9개지 8개
7개 6개
5개
4개
그런 더하면 몇 개가 되겠어
55개가 되겠어요 안 되겠어요
9개나 하나를 더하면 되겠지
[음악]
55개가 되겠습니다
철봉에서 턱걸이를 했대
근데 두 사람의 턱걸이에 합이잖아
철봉이 올라갔다 이렇게
어떤 게임을 했다는 거야
근데
얘를 보자 뭐
어떤 애는 뭔지 모르겠지만
a하고 b를 더하면 얼마겠어
33이겠지 그럼 가장 많이
얼마가 되겠어요
48이 되겠어요 안 되겠어요
요만큼이 얼마씩 차이 난다는 거 알
수 있어 3 근데 다 얼마야 3의
배수가 되겠어요 안 되겠어요 되겠죠
그럼 술을 찍어야 되겠다 안되겠어
제가
해야 되겠지 이해됐어 근데 예를
더하면 얼마야
그럼
얼마야 3의 배수가 돼야 됩니다
그래
그럼 얘는 10일이 되겠지
얘는 27이 되겠어요 안 되겠어요 자
그리고서를 만든지 보자
확인해야 돼 34 36 그리고 39
48 그래서
동욱이는 결국 가장 많이 했으니까
몇 개 27개
됐나요 자 11번 보자
얘는 7위하면 되잖아
근데 얘들아
이걸 보니까
얘랑 얘랑 백의 자리애와 1의 자리가
같은 수가 있는 건 뭐가 있지
가운데 있다 들어가는 건 827이지
얘는 936이 되겠다 안 되겠어 그럼
검은색 페이지를 유지되겠지
검은색 클로바는 1이 되겠죠
답은 761이
갑이 되겠습니다 자
넘어가자
정팔각형의 대각선을 건데
근데 점이 적어도 하나가 있어야 되지
얘는 어떻게 돼 하나씩 늘어난 거지
해볼까 1
1 2 맞지 1 2 3 1 2 3 4
1 2 3
맞지 1 2 3 4 5 1 2 3 4
5 6 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8은 똑같이 여기가 되겠다 안 되겠어
맞지
9는요
이렇게 되겠지 집은요
두 칸 더 가서 얘가 되겠지 11은
태권도가
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
123456789 10 11 12
이렇게 되겠어요 안 되겠어요 되겠지
그러면은
다시 한번 해보죠
헷갈린다 하나 둘 조용히 해 하나 둘
셋
맞죠
1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 5 1
2 3 4 5 6 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
9 10 1 2 3 4
5 6
7 8 9 10 11
12345678910 11
12345678
9 10 11 12 13 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
13 14 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 10 11 12 13 14
15 이렇게 되겠지 일본
묶음이 있고 하나가 더 있는 거잖아
옆에
15개의 점을
찍습니다라고 할 수 있겠네요
그 배는 25명의 선언이 있는데
물에
그런데 12명만 먼저 구명보트에 탈
수 있었어요
25명이 선언이 둥글게
열 번째에 해당하는 선언을 빼고 남은
12명을
태우려고 한대 그럼 처음에는 누가
10번이 없어지겠지 그 다음에는 누가
1번이 되겠어요
얘가 1번이 되겠지 그럼 여기에서 9
더한
20이 없어지겠다는
30이 돼야 되니까 5번이 없어지겠지
이해됐어요 그 다음에 얘가 1이지
그럼 여기에서 하나 둘 셋
넷 다섯 여섯 일곱 여덟 마취 하나
둘 셋 넷 다섯 여섯 일곱 여덟 아홉
열
얘가 없어지는 거지 또 하나 둘
셋 넷 다섯 여섯 일곱 여덟 아홉 열
하나 둘
이렇게 없애면 되잖아 또 하나
둘
셋 넷 다섯 여섯 일곱 여덟 아홉 열
하나 둘
하나
둘 셋 넷 다섯 여섯 일곱 여덟 아홉
열
이제 몇 명이야
12명이야 지금 몇 명이니
9명이지 하나 둘 셋
넷 다섯 여섯 일곱 여덟 아홉 열
하나 둘 셋 넷 다섯 여섯 일곱 여덟
아홉 열 이제 몇 명이야
한번 더 하면 되겠지 하나
둘 셋 넷 다섯 여섯 일곱 여덟 아홉
열
끝났지 그럼 결국
몇 명이 없어졌어
이제 여기에서 또 해야 되지 몇 명
남았어 하나 둘 셋 넷 다섯 여섯
일곱 여덟 아홉 열 11명 남았잖아
이제 됐어 어
그러면
너 많은데
다시
둬야 되는 거 같은데 잠깐 하나 둘
셋
넷 다섯 여섯 일곱 여덟 아홉 열
아까
어디서 끝났지
하나
둘 셋
넷 다섯 여섯 일곱 여덟 아홉 열 3
8 11 12 14 17 18 22
24 23
살
굽이 728이야
얘들아 얘는 어떻게 해야 돼
91이잖아
얘는 7 곱하기 13이 되겠어요 안
되겠어 뭐야 이거
팔하고 13을 더하면 되겠어 안
되겠어
간단한 문제였네요
자 15번
다음에서 연속으로 이웃하는 내게
수행합이 항상 23이 된대 그럼
얘들아 팔아
칠판 봐
여기서부터 여기까지의 학과
여기서부터 여기까지
합이 서로 어때요 같이
얘기는 여기에 있는 마지막 값과요
4개씩 끊어질 값이 항상 어떻다고 할
수 있어요
갖다 갈 수 있어요 없어요
그러면 내가 이렇게 4개씩 끊어 볼게
대체어요
처음에
그런 이유는 자동으로 이게 되겠죠
맨 끝은 팔이 되겠지 그럼 더해서
13이라고 했으니까 얘는 4가 되겠어
안 되겠죠
그래서
기억은 오가 되고요 이유는 6이
되고요 이것은
4 답은 564
맞이라고
자 그 다음 봅시다
자 16번 아니 가득차 이런
정사각형 모양으로 바둑돌을 늘어놓았대
그런데
얘들아 어떻게 늘렸다는
얘기
이렇게 두 줄씩 더 늘린 것이 되는
거지
이해됐어요 자 그럼 봐요
여기는 2가 되겠죠 여기는 네모가
되겠어
여기도 네모가 되겠지 여기는 2가
되겠지 여기는 얼마야
4가 되겠지 여기는
곱하기 네모가 되겠지 여기도 2
곱하기 네모지
근데이 테두리가 24개가 남았는데
20개가 부족했으니까
44개
44가 되는 거지
이해됐어요 그건 내부는 얼마라고 할
수 있어 10이라고 할 수 있어요
없어요 그럼 여기도 10이고 여기도
10이잖아 그런 10 곱하기 12m
100에다가 몇 개를 더해야 돼
24를 더해야 되지
답은
124개가 있겠습니다
자 그다음 17번 바둑돌
4개가 있어
그런데 얘가
55cm의 간격으로 유지석에 놓여져
있대
맞아요
그런데 그런
간격을 얼마야 오지 그건 여기를 몇
개가 있겠어 세 개
얘는 여섯 개니까 다섯 개
얘는 11개니까 10개가 있겠어요
없겠어요 모두 다 더하면 되겠지
답은 18개가 되겠습니다
자 18번
다음과 같이 빨간색 노란색 파란색
신호 깃발이 두 개가 있대요
잘 봐라
얘가 레드일 때는
9가지가
어떤 문제야
서라벌리 맞지
또는 비둘기집의 원리라고 얘기를 하지
이때는요
무엇을 생각하냐면 가장
운이 없는
그런 보자
얘들아 같은 색종이를 3장을 꺼내야
되잖아 거 가장 위에 없을 때는
블루블루 그림 그린 쓸데없는 거
꺼냈겠지 이거를 꺼내봤자 3장이 될
경우가 있어요 없어요 없죠 자
레드
옐로우 옐로우를 꺼냈어 그럼 그
다음에는 무엇이 되든 항상 3장이
되겠어요 안 되겠어 되겠죠 그럼
이때는 몇 개
얘들아 모르겠으면
선생님이 여기에 있는 사키나무를
얘는 옆으로 돌렸으니까 여기는 얼마
되겠어 4가 되겠지
얘는 1이 되겠어요
얘는 6이 되고
5하고 2는 절대 변해야 안 돼요
여기까지 이해됐나요
그럼 여기는 뭐가 되겠어 5가 되겠지
그럼 얘는요
얘는 2가 되겠고 4가 되겠고 3이
되겠고 6하고 1이 안 변하잖아 자
다시
직접 여기는 무조건 뭐가 되겠어
5가 되겠지 왜 하나 둘 셋
넷이니까네 번째니까
얘는 얘랑
얘가 5가 아니라
4개가
되겠어요 안 되겠어요 그럼 얘를
어떻게 됐을 때야
뒤집었을 때가 되겠어 안 되겠어
자 그럼 얘는 얼마야 여기는 6이
되겠어요 안 되겠
어요 여기는 1이 되겠어 안 되겠어
얘는 5가 되고 4하고 3은 바뀌어요
안 바뀌어요 안 바뀌지 그럼 여기는
얼마 되겠니
6이 되겠지
이해됐어 그것도 그려
뭐 그래도 상관없잖아
이렇게 되겠지 그럼 얘를 앞으로
굴리면 얼마야
얘는 3이고 얘는 1이 되겠어 안
되겠어
그러면 얘는
얼마가
6이 되겠어요 안 되겠어요
이해하고 오늘 바뀌어요 안 바뀌어요
하지만 여기는 사고 3이 되겠어 안
되겠어 되겠지 예빈이 그럼 여기는
얼마야
2집
6이지 오직
오가 바닥이면서 사고
뭐 상관은 없잖아
맞지
아 이거 쓰라는 얘기는 아니야
나 이제 해도 돼
내가 예를 그린 거지
얘가
그럼 얘를 돌려야 되잖아
맞지 여기는
1이고 3하고 4가 안 막히잖아 그럼
바닥에서 얘가 1이란 말이야
근데 여기에 4 3인게 없으니까 그냥
그려진 것 뿐이야 선생님은
이렇게 하고 맞으면 되잖아 그치
얘는 얼마야 1이 되겠지 여기는
얼마야 6이 되겠지 2가 되겠고
3하고 4가 되겠어요 안 되겠어요
바닥으로 내려오면 얘는 4가 되겠어
안 되겠어
어 보자 그럼 여기는 2가 되고
얘는 3이 되겠지 이해됐어
그리고
얘는 1하고 6이 되겠죠
근데 얘가 어느 쪽으로 돌리던 여기를
항상 얼마가
되겠어 안 되겠어 되겠지
없어요
[음악]
근데 얘가 최소가 되려면
얘가 하나 나눠주고 하나 주면 되겠어
안 되겠어 그럼 12랑 12랑
8을 해도 돼요 안 돼요 11일 때는
무조건 안 되는 거 알잖아
자 22번 보자
자
1학년 2학년 3학년 4학년 5학년
6학년이 있어요 어
6학년이 아닌 학생을 180년대
그리고
4학년이 아닌 학생은
120명인데
근데
4학년은 6학년을 더했더니
150명이잖아 그럼 1학년부터
6학년까지는
후배가
450명이라고 할 수 있어 없어 그럼
1학년부터 6학년까지가
225명이 되는 거야 안 되는 거야
되는 거지 그럼 결국에
6학년은 몇 명이 되겠어요
225명에서 1학년부터
6학년까지
4학년하고 6학년이 150명 빼주면
되겠어 안 되겠어
[음악]
그림과 같이 1에서 9까지 숫자가
쓰여진 원판에서 1부터 시작해서 한
칸씩 건너뛰었대
얘를 그냥 써볼까 하지만
1이 되겠지
그러면 얘는 뭐야
9개씩 반복되는 거잖아
얘를 어떻게 되겠어
50에서
진짜요
그렇지
51이 되겠어요 안 되겠어요
맞지
51번째 수를 구하는
그런 나누기 두 가지겠지 그런
/가
맞지 그리고 뭐 있어
땡
이게 됐어요
내 자리는
땡땡 일일 이렇게 나눌 수 있어요
없어요
맞지
그러면 모든
숫자들의 합이야
그러면은 뭐야 2가 되겠어 안 되겠어
맞지 자 이때는요
0부터 얼마까지야
0 2 3부터
9까지가 되겠어야 안 되겠어요 여기는
0은 안 되지 일도 안 되지
안 되겠어 중요한 거는 이때는 수가
몇 개야
9개지
이때는 수가 몇 개야
8개가 되겠어 안 되겠어
이해됐어 그럼 얘를 식을 쓰면 얼마가
되겠니 1 + 1이 몇 개가 있어
17개가 있어요 없어요 있죠 그리고
1부터 9까지도 하면 45지만 2부터
9까지도 하면 44가 되겠다 안
되겠어
여기는
40사가 똑같이 되겠어요 안 되겠어요
여기까지 이해됐어 그럼 얘는 34에서
88을 더해야 되겠지
얼마야
122가 되겠니 안 되겠니
물론 이때는
2가 되는 거고요 자 이때는
얘들아
0일 때 2일 때 3일 때
4일 때
5일 때
6일 때
7일 때
9일 때 이렇게 나눌 수 있어요
없어요 있죠 이해됐어
근데 중요한 거
0부터 더하면 여기도 몇 개가 있어
9개가 있지
이때도 아홉 개 이때도 아홉 개
이때도 안
돼 아홉 개가 되겠니 안 되겠죠
여기까지
하나 둘 셋
넷 다섯 여섯 일곱 여덟 아홉 개잖아
그럼 81개잖아 그럼 여기에 있는이가
몇 개가 있겠어
81개가 있겠어요 없겠어요
있겠지 그리고
45가
9개가 있겠어요 없겠어요
그리고 1의 자리에는
얼마야 44지 또 44가 몇 개가
있겠어
하나
둘 셋
넷 다섯 여섯 일곱 여덟 개가 있는
거잖아 그럼
8개가 9개씩이라서 2가
72개가 있겠어 없겠어
있지 또
40사가 9개가 있겠죠 또
40사가 이번에
8개가 있겠어요 없겠어요 왜 앞에
역을 쓸 수가 없으니까 그리고 이때나
얘나 얘나 서로 같겠어 안 갚겠어
2가
72개가 있고
44가
9개가 있고
8개가 있겠어요 없겠어요 있겠죠 이제
계산했죠
이가 몇 개가 있니
153이니까
225개가 있다고 할 수 있어 없어
36의 18이니까 몇 개가 있겠어
54개가 있겠어요 없겠어요
얘는 450이 되겠지
얘는 얼마냐
그럼 6 2
2826개라고 할 수 있어요
답이 되겠습니다
근데 이거 00001이네 이게 0이
하나 더 있어야 되겠네 상가는 없죠
표에 있었으니까
맞지
근데 기프티드를 코드로 술을 나타낼
때
그런 날이 이거 이렇게 할 거야
지는 몇 번째냐
하나 둘 셋 넷 다섯 여섯 일곱
번째지
맞지 그 다음
아이는
8 9번째지
되겠죠
그다음 2는요 몇 번째야 다섯 번째지
d는요네
번째가 되겠어 안 되겠어 근데 이거
되게 됩니다
얘는 1이야
얘는 2지
얘는 1하고 2를 더해서 세 번째
수가 됐지
얘는 뭐야네 번째 수가 되겠어 안
되겠어 그럼 여기 있는 건 1이었고
얘는 4였으니까 다섯 번째가 됐지
그럼 그럼 순서대로
1 2
4 8 16
이런 수가 되겠어요 안 되겠어요
되겠죠
그런데
모두 다 몇 개야 5개씩이잖아
그럼 영어하고 일을 합친 건 몇 개가
되겠어
30개가 되겠어요 안 되겠어요
되겠지 자 칠을 몇 닥이 몇이야
1 + 2 + 4지
9는요 1 + 8이지
6은 2 + 4지 10은
20은 4 + 16이지
5는 1 + 4지
4는 그냥 사지 이거 개수만큼의 1이
되겠어 안 되겠어
하나 둘 셋 넷 다섯 여섯 일곱 여덟
아홉 열 11 12
개가 되겠어 안 되겠어
차이는
6이 되겠습니다
얘들아 마지막네 자릿수를 구하네
얘들아 333이
하나 둘 세 개 빼고는 다 있겠어요
없겠어요
그리고 더하기
369만 하면 되겠어 안 되겠어
그런데
얘는요 3333000에서
그럼 여기다가 369를 더하면 되겠어
안 되겠어
그럼 얘는 얼마가
되겠다 안 되겠어
근데 마지막네 자리 구하라고 했잖아요
몇
명이야
직업을 두 개씩 가지고 있는 거잖아
자 그 다음 순서대로 가수 이발사
대우
감독
약사 주방장
다른 직업이라고 할 수 있어요 없어요
감독과 이발사는 갑을 좋아한대
그러면은
감독도 아니고 이발사도 아니라고 할
수 있어요 없어요 그리고
감독과 이발사도
모르는 사이라고 할 수 있어요 없어요
있죠 자 가수와
배우는 친구래
그러면은 가수와 배우는
다른 사람이라고 할 수 있어요 없어요
이해됐어요
자
을은 뭐가 아니래
이발사가 아니라고 했지 그럼 이발사는
누가 되겠어
병이 되겠다 안 되겠어
그러면은
병은
감독도 아니지
그럼 감독은 누가 되겠어
을이 되겠어요 안 되겠어요
여기까지가 됐나요
이해됐어요 자
그런데
병은 바둑을 두어
을과 과수를 이겼데 그럼 을도 가수도
아니고 병도 가수도 아니잖아 그럼
갑이 가수가 되겠지 그럼 갑은
약간은 아니라고 할 수 있어요 없어요
있죠 그리고 배우도 아니라고 할 수
있어요 없어요
밥은 주방장이 되겠어 안 되겠어
되겠죠
자
배우는 가수가 아닌 사람이 돼야 되고
가수는 약사가 아닌 거지
[음악]
둘 중 하나만 찍으면 되는 거야
자 약사는
아니 이제 해야지
확인할
약산에 다수에게 노래를 불러달라고
했대 아직 약사는 몰라 맞지
근데 약사를 가수가 아니야
감독과 이발사
감독과
이발사는 답을 좋아한다고 했어 마치
여기 이제 필요 없어
자수는
배우와 친구야
우선 이거 몰라 맞지
아
끝났다
을과 가수를 이겼다고 했잖아
그럼 병이나 우리
배우가 되는 거잖아
맞지
자
약사는 어디 갔어
감독한테 아 이거를 빼놨구나
그럼 얘랑
얘랑도 다른 애지
맞죠 그럼 얘는 아닌 거지
끝났다
답을 안 써줘도 알겠지
그 다음 넘어갈게요
자 28번
4개 의자가 있대
자 쉬는 동안 자리를 비우는 돌아와서
자리에
앉는 경우는 누구의
몇 가지입니까라고 했었지
자 abcd 자리가 다 여기라고
해보자
a만 같으려면
얘가 자리에 앉지 않는 점은 몇
가지가 있어
c가 여기 있으면
비비잖아
뒤면
bc인가
a가 여길 때 b가 여기일 때 c가
여기다
abc도
자 1부터 5까지의
비밀번호를 만든대
그런데 두 종류의 숫자로만 된
비밀번호를 모두 몇가지입니까라고 했지
얘들아 내가요
5개 중에 두 개를 선택하는 경우의
수는
10개가 되겠어요
그런데 만약에 일하고 2를 가지고
비밀번호를 만든다고 생각해 보자 그럼
1 1 1 2 3개인 경우
2가 두 개인 경우
이 경우가 있겠어요 없겠어요
그러면 이때는 몇 가지야
6가지가 됐어요 안 됐어요 이때도
4가지가 되겠지 아 이거는 길
찾기잖아 바로바로
그런 얘는 뭐야 14가지지
140까지
얘들아 어떤 친구도 있어 선생님 내
자리인데 왜 이렇게 밖에 없어요라고
나한테 물어
봤냐고 지금은
0이 되겠지
맞죠 그리고 기억은 예를 보면 당연히
뭐가 되겠어 3이 되겠어요 안
되겠어요 되겠지 하다 보면
320-320
1 나오겠습니다